again
um today i want to do a video about
language learning and
age
and i'm doing this because i received
um a comment on my youtube channel from
a gentleman in
gee i think it was peru but somewhere in
latin america
who said that he was very encouraged by
my videos
and that he was interested in learning
english and that he was 75 years old
and it made me realize that um you know
and i perhaps i should also say that i
had the dinner with the family uh recent
immigrants from china and their
12 year old son
and they were very keen that the sun
should learn you know not only he speaks
english very well but learn other
languages and and they sort of seem to
feel that they were
too old to do it and they were probably
in their mid 40s
so i thought about you know and then my
in my own case i guess since 19 since
the age of 55 i've got
you know have become very interested in
learning more and more languages so
let's just look at this issue of of
language learning and age
um
first of all uh you know i can say as
someone who is going to be 67 in october
that i don't feel any older than i did
30 years ago
i mean yeah
in a way like
my body i mean if i go jogging for too
long i get stiffer than i did before
but uh
yeah i don't really feel that very
different i know that i
look
different i looked much younger 30 years
ago even
20 years ago and
that's fine but
i'm the same person
and uh you know we can only live
we can only live our life you know in
the present that's the only time we
actually live it we can prepare for
things in the future but we can only
really enjoy
the moment
yeah we can enjoy anticipation as well
and i guess as you get older you've got
less things to anticipate in terms of
the number of years in front of you
but in terms of living your day-to-day
life i don't feel that it makes much
difference
so if i look at the enjoyment that i get
from
learning languages
um i mean when i listen to
my russian
radio when i read in russian and now in
czech when i'm discovering so much about
the lives and the history of people
in the czech republic of the history of
czechoslovakia or the austro-hungarian
empire when i talked to
my czech tutors through skype uh when
i'm able to listen to
uh an interview and you know these daily
interviews yaktovidi for example where
they're talking to different people and
i'm able to follow exactly what they say
i mean in some instances i know i i
listen and read at the same time and i
essentially know every word
there
um
sometimes i don't sometimes i don't
understand it
i mean the enjoyment is tremendous when
i go to prague
in
october not only will i be able to
communicate with people will i be able
to read the signs read the newspapers
understand what people are saying i will
have
much more knowledge about the history of
the country the history of the city the
different buildings you know the
national theater whatever it might be
charles bridge who was charles iv
um all this kind of stuff i mean it is
so rewarding and it doesn't matter
whether you're 35 55 65 75 85 i have a
friend who's 83 and he's studying
spanish and he loves doing it and he
reads spanish novels or latin american
novels
um
you know i mean age it's it's it's it's
interesting the perspective we have on
age uh i remember when i was uh working
for a large company here in vancouver at
the age of say
30 whatever i was mid 30s we had a vice
president i guess who was in his he was
53 and he used to go kayaking uh you
know in the ocean and i thought wow
that's amazing for someone 53. well i'm
67 almost 66 i go kayaking in the ocean
um
yeah whatever i mean i think
uh i certainly don't think that our
brain cells
there's undoubtedly some deterioration i
mean i
uh you know uh expert on the physiology
of the body but
i mean i've i've been uh less than a
year on check and uh
i understand a lot i'm doing great with
my check
i think i've learned it faster than any
other language given the time that i've
spent on it granted i had the russian
beforehand but now if you say russian
and czech i'm into this slavic world
that was never a part of anything that i
understood before and now i'm able to
be conversing with it and understand it
and understand some of the issues and
when i finish that i'm going to go back
to korean and bring my korean up to a
decent level
it's it's just it just gives you so much
it really doesn't matter
and and every minute that i'm involved
with these languages i'm deriving
tremendous enjoyment and when i
encounter people even again like last
night with these chinese people to speak
in chinese for the whole evening it's a
great sense of enjoyment obviously
that's a language that i learned 40
years ago
but if i had had if i had an opportunity
to spend an evening with some russian
people or check people then i'd have
that sense of enjoyment and achievement
so
to me it doesn't matter what age you are
now
because i'm not an expert i won't i
can't really get into the subject of how
learning
uh foreign languages is good for the
brain and staves off alzheimer and so
forth alzheimer's it's possibly true i
don't know but i'm sure it's good for
the brain to continue to challenge the
brain
and i also am quite convinced from my
reading that
when the brain is challenged and then is
able to
you know cope with the challenge and
overcome the obstacles and achieve
certain things
the brain has a sense of of satisfaction
and so that has to be healthy it has to
be healthy in the same senses as
exercising is healthy and of course i
also exercise
uh physically
so i guess the whole the point of all
this is to say that we often think of
language learning as something that
kids are better at and in many ways in
terms of quickly assimilating a new
accent and new phraseology the kids seem
to have less resistance to change and
therefore they adapt to the new language
more quickly
but um
we can all do it
um it's not something that should be
reserved for kids
it's not something that's reserved for
any particular age and there's no reason
why
uh people of any age including older
people whatever that means is 50 older
60 older 70 80. whatever the age is i
think that there's tremendous enjoyment
uh that we can achieve from language
learning and it's never too late to
start and so i i am this is
uh thanks to the gentleman in i think it
was peru who commented on one of my
spanish videos and perhaps i should do
the video also in spanish and send it to
him but good for him at 75 and i hope to
be with him 10 years from now and he'll
be presumably on another language
when he's 85 so thanks for listening bye
for now